[Music]
New York honestly my biggest fear at
this point is that I've run away so
let's not do that
and let us go to Carnegie Hall let me
first make sure that I didn't forget my
hotel key I totally did there it is all
I need from a camera and my voice look
who I just ran into in the elevator
Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
the abilities are so high
look who's in the stairway
[Applause]
[Music]
all righty first just did my first thing
I'm gonna casino going back to change
out of my tuxedo wardrobe change
I'm a little freaked out
[Music]
there will be peace day
Angelo's
yes
[Music]
if it kills me
hit through the
if it chills me
we did we so did it people who didn't
get a chance to see it I'm very glad
that we have been able to preserve it on
the vlog with this channel if you'd like
to watch the evening of awesome if you
got a couple of hours to kill I think
it's worth the pop some popcorn there's
a link in the description thank you to
Neil Gaiman to commute us into the
mountain goats to Ashley and Daniel to
Hanna and grace and Elise and our
parents and our wives and all of
nerdfighteria for it and making this
thing possible gone we're very lucky
things like this are very clearly gifts
that not very many people get a lot of
times you'll hear people say the life is
affair and I can unequivocally confirm
that I have clearly gotten the long end
of the stick as a reward for giving me
that long stick everybody here's a video
of me doing my little dance before the
show it didn't turn out quite this good
but it was pretty good John I'll see you
on Tuesday and while all this was going
on we were also launching brain scoop
like there wasn't enough going on in my
life so if you want to check that out in
youtube.com slash the brain scoop here's
a clip
[Music]
wow you guys that first video was really
awesome I am so incredibly excited about
doing this and working with you guys to
make this show so totally awesome
I was mentioned on the Scientific
American website I mean that's pretty
awesome smiley share MOC asked are there
lots of animal ghosts
wilt opal on Twitter is wandering
children what is the silliest thing we
have ever asked you on a tour they
always ask if everything is dead is that
dead is that dead is that dead is that
dead yes you guys everything is dead